you know Jim Norton I know you rich Voss
how you doing hey rich is going on now
rich we've met but yeah we got all this
we met you no no we read this chrismole
we you were on the roast of Christopher
Walken was on it who did you roast years
ago no I was right that was a real
arriving for when Belzer Richard Belzer
we're I thought it was hosting it but
who they roasting Chris Maloney was on
that roast only who the [ __ ] did no Paul
Shaffer hosted it they were roasting
bells okay do you remember the Richard
Belzer roast Chris no I don't remember
any of those years you don't think that
day not that I should remember these
years he was in studio when you were in
the morning before maybe you are oh yes
you might name it with another guy duh
when the movie was coming out uh oh the
guy with the movie you guys right know
what's in the man with the camera yes I
remember I remember he was your studio I
don't remember who the guy was where are
you think I can't remember
yes you know rich she's already I never
I don't remember all right we're on time
so I try to cut off a couple letter
sides Marcela Belinda male voice Karen
smart are we on right now we are oh my
yeah we are on that's why I was trying
to figure out if you don't remember the
roast the belt it was the Belzer roast
you're right and you know as everybody
from the from the show that went up and
roast him and walk in I bothered you
first of all like actually go in the
bathroom yeah I got the pictures have
been with pee stains do you really yes
good we don't have a bathroom I piece me
you don't remember they memorabilia yeah
that's called
is that is that where do you realize
that like there are fans of yours
they're like oh my god I got a
christopher meloni picture with pee
stains on it
oh they got more than that is that right
I mean you know I did five years of I've
got a lot of stains whether we're doing
those scene I mean I know you've been
asked before and so it's a very basic
question but is it like because if you
have to if you have to gear up to kiss
somebody I know obviously it's just one
of those things as an actor you got to
do what the first time you do it is it
really difficult no because you know
it's like gearing up for a football game
it's like you got to go across the
middle I'm not worried I'm going to come
during a football game
I'm gonna need a bigger job around about
going over the middle so the first time
he did you talk to the first time I
kissed a woman I've only done like two
on-screen kisses but I talked to you was
nina hartley the porn star for this
independent comedy and I asked you like
do we use tongue I didn't know what we
were supposed to do or what was the
process and when your kid when you're
doing that kiss do you stay with you and
Nina now yeah why hasn't her all know
ahead no because it was she did porn so
I wanted to be actually extra respectful
because I think if I did it wrong and
she's a porn girl she'd be like what you
think I do porn you could suck at
reality right yeah so I walked up to it
before the shoot I'm like Dina I've
never kissed a girl on screen do we use
tongue this was her dressing room and
she goes killing her baby and she made
out with me in the dressing room and
then during the shoot she's taking my
hand and she's putting on her breasts
and she'll you know you want to and my
hands are on her ass she's like we're
supposed to like each other so she was
so great incredible yeah I was
legitimately turned on like she was
really sex that's how Lea targets and I
want to believe me have a left like that
you guys kind of get kissed a little and
got yous known as the nina hartley of
actors but kissing a man's just got to
be again it's one of those things you do
and I've seen other actors do it like I
think Will Smith didn't want to do it
though in the young yeah we already said
later here is a separation he did regret
not doing it he said when he was young
he had you just like yeah an ego
decision and it was sort of like I'm not
gonna do that and then as he grew up and
I guess the world changed as well he was
like that was a stupid as a stupid call
on my part I should have done it yeah
have you been asked to do things you
didn't want to do in scripts or even do
lines of reality
yeah in reality I wasn't being anything
I got to where I am in my career yeah
what was the question do you ever have
things that they want you to do that you
don't want to do yeah but that's just
that only has to do with well I don't
understand like you know you have a
character doing X Y & Z and then all of
a sudden you have them doing a potato
pancake and you like that that doesn't
that's not in part of this equation I
don't know why that his character all of
a sudden is doing this so just explain
to me and I'll do it okay if I can
understand it and that's how it is it's
never it's almost
rarely or if it's gratuitous like you
know Viton like I love a nice violent
movie as much as the nature but it has
to be logical as opposed to kind of a
that bloodbath just Gore for Gore sake
I'm not into that doesn't really appeal
to me you know that's how I feel and
let's do some of the beauty like you
watch a John Woo movie and India the
canary in the ballet and you know that
the cameras going to be taken over so
much of this work I mean look when you
have these two assassins doing all these
cartwheels shooting at each other
everything is the may mayhem and all
sudden they wind up gun the gun in each
other's face and neither pulls the
trigger you're like okay and there's a
blind girl who doesn't know what's
happening Miller in the killer there's a
blind girl and they named each other
Mickey Mouse and Dumbo and they do
something and they're both pointing guns
in each other's faces and the blind
girls like what's happening and they're
both trying to talk calmly so that she
doesn't know that they're about to kill
each other it was such it but you're
right there's like a ballet to it yeah
you take a little bit beyond just being
violent yeah
do you enjoy the freedom of like because
you go from Oz yeah where Reno's use
Chris Keller to law-and-order where
everybody knows you is Stabler do you
like the fact that now is in spend a few
years as much as people will still
associate with you with those characters
because they're still watching the shows
it's not like something that you're
actively doing week to week you're not
in their living room week to week so
it's a different deal I feel like
getting away from doing a regular show
since you've been working steadily would
mean that you have more of like a life
and you get to be you more if that makes
sense yeah you know if you had a big
footprint in my life and I've worked
intentionally and not without great
respect and love for the stuff that I've
done before but you know I'm on a show
now called underground on WGN America
you know
I'm here with snatched the movie with
you know Goldie Hawn and Amy Schumer and
which is a comedy I got the second
season of wet hot American summer coming
out oh they argue identities yeah
estimated I got to be coming out in the
summer and so you know those things
that's great but I'm always kind of like
pushing forward and young going out on
these you know
little uh junkets yes I hey this is
what's up next yeah I hope you follow
you continue to follow me right you know
but I recognize it as look there there
rerun 24/7 around the world so you know
I'm interested in the fact that you're a
pilot but that to me is amazing to take
but yeah there's only a couple of
celebrities I can think of yourself
Travolta and Bruce Dickinson who can
actually fly lit you could like
commercial jet I can fly my jet because
every jet you know kind of has their own
little buttons bells and whistles that
you have to know the sequence to push
them in and all that stuff so I'm type
rated for my particular jet do it do you
still have to audition or do cursive
your experience on yeah on everything or
you never just get offered it and no io
you sail first snatched yeah go went on
in there and I did the character Roger
for the director and he laughed a lot
and I was like I think that's a good
sign but you know they've done that
before and yeah that's a cool I get that
reaction when I audition for dramas yes
but that's part of doing different stuff
right like you have to audition because
otherwise you're just if you're not
auditioning then you're getting that
same sort of typecast roles and people
know you from there you go that's a
great example I mean you know if you
wants that you it's like anything in
life you want something you have to
continually fight for it because people
especially in this business they see you
in a certain way and they also recognize
it well you know the audience kind of
knows him in a certain way so you know I
started out I did I got my first break
said let in sitcoms when sitcoms were
popular for 30 years ago and so people
always knew me as oh that kind of
lovable lunk funny guy it took a you
know a couple years to also do a little
bit of drama stuff and people recognized
me as that and similar suddenly got kind
of typecast for the drama guy so yeah
yeah so if you had need like any real
problems while you were fun fascinated
by anybody that wants to Duvall interior
have you had any like close calls out
there any real issues well you know
they're close calls only to the degree
of what your knowledge is so you know
meaning you know I flew into a rainstorm
one time when I was only four months
deep into my training and you know that
is a cataclysmic event you know people
can you know
people have accidents let me ask you did
you have will you instrument-rated at
that point like they said JFK jr. was I
like invest early in generated so he
couldn't yeah yeah those were a lotta
those were a lot of bad decisions but
yeah I was not instrument-rated I was
working towards it so you know I flew
into something that was above my pay
grade okay
and so you're all along the way I've
bumped into stuff that caused the things
to tighten and pores to open yeah and
you really the heart to pound and but I
was able to get out of it and in
retrospect you realize oh oh that yeah
that was that was it just enough
challenge to scare me to make a big
impression but it wasn't you know just
so far above my pay grade that I got
hurt what scared you like when you walk
in with you arranged no it's obviously
bumpy but as the pilot when you fly into
a rainstorm what's scary about it well
in this particular one uh because it was
almost like an optical illusion I was
looking into the distance going kind you
know had that I think that's rain like
way in the distance like you know 200
miles that's just like oh there's a--
and then all of a sudden it's like i
flew through a carwash
i just going really oh my god what have
I done
and I didn't know what to do so I just I
said okay let's calm down and you know
I'm simply going do I do a 180 and from
go back go back do I fly through and I
just thought you know this is so intense
and I was looking at my little ray and
it wasn't picking up on my little radar
thing it was weird so I just thought if
I keep going you know I'm feeling that
it's not that long side way it lasted
about five minutes which a lot or five
minutes the longest five minutes you'll
ever have because all you hear is the
engine you know you hear everything
every sentence become a lot what I was
playing with it that was a call it was a
Saratoga actually the same plane that
JFK was said Oh what was it so the thing
was he can become disoriented in clouds
or at night yes it's hard to tell what
what's often yet up yeah then that's the
issue that's why you get an instrument
rating because when
you have no visual cues you stuff your
head down into all those dopey little
enjoyments that you see in front of you
and every one of those instruments is
telling you a story and you just have to
rely on those instruments and you it's
not one instrument you have to do the
scan you just caught your eyes or cause
it's exhausting you're constantly just
scanning the instruments making sure
your speeds correct your wings are level
your altitude is right that's all how if
not instinct it's like I know like the
science behind this is this is the speed
of us supposed to be going at this is
where the altitude is supposed to be
it's not like when you're driving and
you kind of look out the window and just
see the other guy's driving but here and
here's the human thing about driving
driving is you're just going it's a
linear movement right it's not up down
right that is that's the trick to it
also you know if you're flying blind and
all sudden your engine starts revving
kind of high well you probably
nose-diving yeah you're picking up speed
wrong how do you have that happen in my
training sessions with a blindfold
you'll cap over my eyes and again I'll
talk about your pours opening up with
the cap on your eyes for so you don't
look outside the window because you
train you'll train during very beautiful
days but they want it they want to give
you the impression that okay it's really
dark out or you're in a urine clouds so
you can't see you can't rely on visual
cues your forces look at your instrument
so they want you to use the instruments
and yeah how when you went into that
rain were you hitting tremendous
turbulence or was it not bad No thank
God no does that scare you as a pilot I
always freak out but we are the pilots
are probably comfortable with other
pilots nervous during turbulence well
yeah we'll only Hawk oh I think about no
because I just went to I've my worst
turbulence meaning where it jacked me
out of the seat my head [ __ ] my
headphones went flying Wow
yeah you're just rented for a moment
I've had a couple of those turbulent
times we just don't see it's like clear
air turbulence we just drop yeah yeah
you just have you know wind shear and
you know just bad what's that what's
that
to fly like I couldn't imagine me ever
wanting to fly an airplane yeah me
neither I don't know you know John
Travolta took me up in this plane and I
had never had any inclination to 707
it-- that's one of them
oh yes more than one oh yeah yeah I mean
he lives in an aviation community
yeah he's locked and loaded yeah where'd
you get the money did I oh yeah is John
Travolta but he inspires you to want to
fly yeah yeah I couldn't get it out of
my mind I took what he just like did you
just know have you known him for a long
time and he's like come up in my plane
one day no you know we met and then you
know got to be friends and he invited me
and my family down to his place and it
was great hanging out with him and Kelly
and and I was just enamored with this
plane in his front yard
and ice and I just kept asking questions
and he just says well let me take you up
he was gracious enough to try he's right
in his yard right but yeah he just kind
of walks outside and to get onto it so I
got a row in his yard where it's just
like yeah a community yeah and you just
instance you've heard of a carport sure
he has a plane port literally because
it's the Florida Sun and you know big
overhang to keep the plane out of the
Sun and you're just Ken barbecuing one
man in the next minute I gotta take you
up yeah Wow how long does it take him
and does he have a crew that helps him
get the plane it could be a few all
kinds of instrument checks and stuff to
start so does he have people that are
doing that for him and helping him like
co-pilots or is he doing all that
himself oh yeah on this particular plane
yeah but you know I mean he's got a
pretty cool infrastructure I mean it
really is set up as a tiny Airport he's
got all the trappings it's amazing yeah
I mean he's really an aviation nut well
he'll fly like legitimate you fight for
quasi real limits with real passengers
like he's qualified to the highest level
I believe yeah I think he's got a 707
and 747 typewriting so when he when he
says Oh Johnson okay I'm up in the plane
let's let's say I'll take you for right
how long does it take that whole process
to happen to get ready there's a half
hours and 45 minutes the plane no but
for him to do
the checksum remember there was nothing
we know we jumped in he went beat bop
boop with all the things and just taxied
on out it probably took 15 minutes and
where did you did you fly rifle a while
yeah flew around we did figure Eight's
my wife was on the ground and she said
it looks so cool she said you look like
you were going 500 miles an hour you
scared no it was fascinating I was
fascinated by it I want to know which
one of those simulators where looks like
you could just watch Sully and it's
amazing how one movie can show the same
plane incident eight times right so when
I watched it I'm like obviously there's
nothing going on with this dude because
he's watched the crash in real time at
least four times in that really still is
they know to watch I just wish it was in
3d and the to watch to watch the the
simulations look fun like I want to go
into a simulator
don't forget nauseous on virtual
rollercoasters I did yeah but in a
simulator I might knocks I've flown so
many times how many hours of training is
it take before you you can get a license
that's up to you
it took me four hundred now is that
standard that low or high I have no idea
oh yeah it's a lot of hours was two out
of two years all okay so long like two
years it took me and you get a lot of
you get like a lot of recognition from
the elders I always you know the gay
community L LGBT LBGT I never goes for
doing work and for like yes fighting for
the cause oh I'd say yeah yeah yeah um
[Music]
yeah it's outside I feel very connected
to okay is it because of the roles you
played or because of your unashamed to
do certain things as an actor I think
eyes I think eyes was a big deal I
because I think Oz you know was one of
the if not the first show to show
unflinchingly you know two men in love
or in lust whatever you want to coin the
relationship and I think a wedding on
the episode yeah depending on the
episode and also I think when this is
what they think they appreciate was it
wasn't that classic effeminate you know
you yeah yeah I'm a guy yeah this is
what it is right as what it is right and
I think they appreciated that but you
didn't yeah you didn't caricature it
yeah okay cool yeah and I was really
you've gotten award so
smash your Namie's movie uh you are you
play who do you play I play Roger
mysterious strangers they meet deep in
the Amazon jungle
okay sounds perfect I know yeah my voice
is sexy if you match is thank you I
believe you and that comes out when that
comes out this Friday yeah and the
premiere is when I Wednesday night I'm
gonna premiere it are you yeah have you
seen it no yeah right do you get really
before they say you have to go to before
we let's Krista do you get worried
watching yourself I don't like watching
myself no I'm really and and I hate that
I don't like watching myself I find it
indulgent and somehow and I also find it
non unproductive but do you when you
what I help do you not like the work are
you going I don't like my job my what a
job I did I don't like the you know we
all have the angel in the devil all I
got is the [ __ ] devil on my shoulder
one of the edge to devil's lair
yeah just enjoy yourself we're occurring
alone let me ask you before you go was
there more sexual tension between you
and Mariska Hargitay or you and liter
Kissin off off behind the scenes where
was there more sexual tension because
that I mean these these kind of couples
are the green girls oh I would say me
and Goldie Hawn okay then we got to see
this movement yes all right well good
luck with it it's Chris underscore
Maloney on Twitter yeah
are you verified URI show you a thing
you had a little pilot pictures yeah
okay in case you didn't know yeah what
means how I found out though is look I
didn't know until I saw your Twitter
avatar was a bigger deal when you got
your pilot license or when you got
verified on Twitter Oh
Twitter that's a good one yeah yeah you
already I caught me I'm so obvious